hey guys yes with today today is
football day Matt is in here watching
the game
oh you watch all by himself we are
finally going to be making some Auntie
Anne's Pretzels you guys might remember
we bought these back when we were home
for Christmas today is the day
French Afghan Santino we're also here
Ava hello hello do you think this is the
toy the microphone pineda brightly woman
yes let's go here we go pretzels here we
go so let's make pretzels and go to the
Super Bowl
oh here we go no you hang them in the
bag I mean c'mon sign how do the polical
feel nice
just remember where we go
mmm
[Music]
thank you
okay no yeah the ratios are going to be
off really yeah just a little bail on
every would read it matter
[Music]
okay okay you honey do you have that and
then you need it the Brussels the
pretzels
what do we do after this we've tasted
okay well I need your fat away hey
yourself do I need your dough right now
and you're up nuts watch your hands your
neck okay
and we're bridge yeah and then put it
back in the wall
ah okay now we let it rise but we have
to cover it with a plastic wrap you know
no biggie ziplock bag
my turtlenecks in the way what if we
can't get it out how can we cut it just
go ahead oh yeah Fidel's rising football
still on Matt ordered pizza from like 17
different restaurants how many different
pieces you or there's only one and Wendy
okay that's cool I learned some salad
for me and Francesca I ordered Wendy's
and they show up
finally after half an hour at the front
door they knock I open it up and this
guy hands me jack-in-the-box so I said
to him hey man I think it's supposed to
be Wendy's they said are you sure I'm
pretty sure and he's like well do you
want it and I'm like I kind of wanted to
Wendy's here we are
he ordered wedgies again so an
interesting story it's a good story
alive what is this my cookie jar now OOP
to roll out June 15 just a lyric roll
yeah yeah it is I'm pretty sure
I don't get it here that looks like a
puzzle let me look
oh you have to do a twist in the shout
there yeah
[Music]
thank you
last one
the game is not going in our favor at
all but what is going in the favor is
Santino in VR I am having a great time
we're gonna open up the cake now cause
of all I just guys lots of super move
okay boy yes I thought there's okay
there's butter on my lens like this is
disgusting
oh right back
the cake looks good thank you
I knew you could do it thank you like my
VR my VR Marc please guys an example we
made a big cake I think I've mastered
cakes now and putting have really good
it's really light mm-hmm tell me more
about how great it is okay that's dozen
vanilla ice cream for this you would be
I've got hey little top it's progressive
protein ice cream for Fitness people
give which obviously we are 2 or 80
calories per pint we can eat the whole
thing all I've done guys work oh here's
real ice cream
I wash I bring this evening to a close
Sheila's lost which means I don't think
I am I going super bowl now I mean like
oh so sad I really want to play in high
hopes Matt did you meet you much today I
did hmm okay well I'm gonna go shoot a
video now I hope you guys have a good
night
how was the pizza today Papa John's good
I give you good honest lp3 you I hate
you I don't like your disgusting keep it
I think hi right Matt is an actual human
Pig
well thank you for all of the great
comments on my cage video I'm glad that
it actually turned out well I'm sad the
game did not turn out better and that's
all I've got to say I put them by the
door
I put your shoes where they belong oh no
like if you took your shoes up by the
door like before you came in the house
should be resent you know like a proper
man Maddie's a proper man oh you're cute
alright guys bye I'll see you whenever I
see you peace let's race blah oh great
bwah chocolate cake are you actually
gonna baby yes I'm actually I think I'm
a nerd here and my standards are super
low I think I've perfected how to make
cakes now in the blondie what's wrong
so basically